okay real quick voicemail about
vaccinations take a listen to this yeah
hey David Stan & moreno valley' I really
like your show but I have a question if
if and when the core virus vaccine
becomes available would you be raising
your hand to be first in line to get the
vaccine the reason I asked is because I
noticed your seem to be very critical of
anti-vaxxers well yeah and it's not that
I'm an anti backer or anything like that
but I think I'm not nearly as confident
as you are is about the use of them so
I'd appreciate an answer on that
the answer is I will absolutely be at
the front of the line now I won't be
allowed at the front of the line in the
sense that the vaccine after being
tested on thousands and thousands of
people in each each vaccine will be
tested on many many people the first few
million doses are going to go to
healthcare workers the next ones are
going to go to healthcare workers and
the most vulnerable population so even
if I wanted to be first in line for the
vaccine once it had been properly tested
I'm not going to be first in line right
because as someone in my 30s without
pre-existing conditions there is not a
priority to get me the vaccine health
care workers and vulnerable people but
yes I will be there looking to get a
corona virus vaccine make sure you don't
miss today's bonus show get instant
access by becoming a member at join
pakman.com I will see you on the bonus
show